when you think about education and
self-education what do you recommend I'd
encourage people to read a lot of books
basically try to ingest as much
information as you can also just develop
a good general knowledge try to learn a
little bit about about a lot of things
how would you know what you're really
interested in if you at least aren't
like doing a peripheral exploration or
broadly of the knowledge you talk to
people from different walks of life and
different Industries and professions and
skills and occupations like just try to
learn as much as possible I would
encourage people to read broadly in many
different subject areas try to find
something where there's an overlap of
your talents and what you're interested
in so you want to try to find a good
combination of the things that you're
inherently good at but you also like
doing hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because the thing that
saved me as an entrepreneur was watching
the stories of other successful
entrepreneurs and I learned from their
advice I learned from their motivation
and honestly I have no idea where I
would be if I didn't have those videos
to inspire me I still need them for
myself today too and I hope that they
can inspire you as well so today let's
learn from Bill ionaires on how you can
build your wealth
enjoy
rule number two is analyze your
competition with Warren Buffett you have
a competitive Spirit clearly yeah
clearly well but you gotta you gotta be
careful about what you compete in you
know it's a good thing I don't have a
competitive Spirit In chess or you know
you know or football or anything like
that oh I just I've I've been an
observer there I I enjoy watching things
like that
but I I try to keep my competitive
spirit in a game where I can win do you
have a killer instinct
nah not exactly I've got I wouldn't call
it a Killer Instinct but I do I do know
this well I want to do something I
always want to do it big
I put my whole net worth in City service
preferred you know 120 dollars
114.75 and I put my whole net worth and
and I've never
since I was
well since that day and
you know March 11
1942. I have never had less than 80
percent of my money in American business
you can call them stocks or equities but
I see them as American Business I I've
owned a piece of American Business
for
eight at least 80 percent
at all times and you know I've just I
don't want to own anything else I want
to own a home and you know things my
family wants and all that but owning
five homes doesn't mean anything to me
because I'm I'm gonna be happy in one
almond and there's a certain amount of
things that go wrong with everything and
if I got two homes I know I've got more
problems and I don't have more happiness
what brings you to happiness oh that
yeah
I would have to be honestly say that
that what makes me happiest is what I'm
doing what I'm doing you know I I
allocating I enjoy two things about it
one
I know I'll win over time that's mean
I'll beat everybody else or anything
like that but I I mean the game is very
very very easy if you have the right
lessons in your mind about what you're
buying I'm not buying stocks on my
pieces of overwhelmingly American
Business uh and I'm happy
when I was happy when that's uh when I'm
doing it I'm happy when stocks are going
down I'm happier when stocks are going
down because I I can buy more of them
with the same amount of money I'd be
happy if I was a farmer I'd want
Farmland to go down uh so I could buy
more acreage you know if I was I mean it
just makes sense rule number three is
know how to sell with Mark Cuban you
gotta sell yeah because the in my
experiences the the CEOs the owners the
founders that didn't sell they all
failed yeah with no exceptions a hundred
percent of them failed and you know when
you're just starting and it's just you
who else is going to sell nobody
and that's the other you know and that
leads to another mistake entrepreneurs
make they they try to hit hiring home
runs right so when the minute they hit a
roadblock I'll just hire a you know I'll
hire a new marketing person right or
I'll hire a new head of sales
um hope thinking that oh this person's
amazing no one's ever hired somebody and
said they suck really bad of course
right oh I found the most amazing person
why did they leave the last five jobs oh
they were amazing but right
um that's such a good point see that's
what I love how your brain works it's
like exactly it's so true it's so
practical and common sense it's
pragmatic yeah right common sense but
Common Sense isn't so common no I know
you know you just ask why why'd they
leave you know but but entrepreneurs
tend to think okay I'm hiring this
amazing marketing person and he or she
is is going to know what to do yeah and
then they tell that to their investors
because that's typically why they're
hiring a marketing person and they say
oh this person's amazing you know our
next quarter is going to be great then
it's not then they go to the next
marketing person you know then they're
in this hamster wheel again and they're
screwed and so we're relying on other
people well yes and that's the whole
thing right you you've got to be able to
solve the problems yourself self-reliant
now you know at some point your business
gets bigger and you have to learn how to
do a lot of other things you know when
you go to five people it's one thing you
go to 10 or 15 it's another challenge
you know as you learn how to manage and
deal with people but at the same time if
you're not great at your core competency
how are you going to train those people
right how are you going to know what the
the goals are for the organization how
to communicate to them how to do what
you need them to do also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is stay within
your expertise with Bill Gates the
biggest impact a company can have is
staying within its area of expertise so
you know to make sure that the education
systems around the world that they get
good software and we have a donation
program where we've done called called
Partners in learning we have deals with
132 countries how we grant them software
and fun teacher training in each of
those countries so Microsoft's main
thing will be about that Library access
that school access the free software the
training you know the job skills and the
partners that are in that country uh not
not so much health care and whereas the
big drug companies we need to get them
into the health care issues and the
banks we need to get into microfinance
and the food companies we need to get
into micronutrients and buying the
output of the farmers in these poor
countries so that the their economies
get going so I think everybody's got a
big role to play but it's it's going to
be fairly centered on the thing that
that the employees know and uh drives
their their specific contribution rule
number five is be Innovative with Jeff
Bezos Jeff you've built one of the
greatest technology companies in the
world in just 20 some years you've taken
a company from nothing to Amazon which
everybody in the world now knows and and
most people in the world seem to use was
that harder to do than trying to get a
space company off the ground which is
more of a challenge to you
totally different challenges so one of
the things that I find if I think back
on the last 20 years you have to
remember 20 years ago I was driving the
packages to the post office myself in my
1987 Chevy Blazer dreaming that one day
I might be able to afford a forklift and
the internet that's 1995 and you know 21
years later the internet is this
gigantic thing and there are many many
successful companies and
the entrepreneurial dynamism
that you see on the internet is
incredible and really with blue origin
you know that this new challenge that
I'm taking on with blue origin what I
want to do is put the heavy lifting
infrastructure in place so that the Next
Generation can have a dynamic
entrepreneurial explosion of ideas and
inventions in space just like we've had
with the internet and the reason you
can't do that today is because there's
just too much heavy lifting involved
literally you know getting to space is
so expensive and so hard when we started
Amazon I didn't have to build a
logistics infrastructure system to
deliver Parcels there was something
already UPS already existed in the U.S
Postal Service already existed I didn't
need to build a remote payment system
there are already credit cards and
similarly you know there were computers
around and you know that didn't have to
get all those things would have been
tens of billions or hundreds of billions
of dollars of infrastructure the long
distance phone network became the
backbone of the internet but it already
existed and so you could have this
Dynamic entrepreneurial explosion
because all the heavy capex
infrastructure was in place for space
it's not like that the price of
admission is so high so that's the big
difference and what I'm super excited
about is lowering that cost I want to
dramatically lower that cost so that 20
years from now a new generation of
people with startup money real real
entrepreneurs small entrepreneurs can do
amazing things in space think how cool
that would be rule number six is just do
it with Richard Branson I've always uh
had the philosophy that's you know screw
it uh just do it is a lot more fun than
um than not screwing it and not doing
um and um and sometimes it's got me into
a lot of trouble uh and sometimes uh
more often than not it's been it's been
fantastic and
um so you know I suppose one of my
greatest fear in life is saying no to
something and then regretting it so
um so I have said yes a lot and um and
in the case of um you know the learning
Adventures
um yeah the helicoster's my life but it
it helped put virgin on the map on a
global basis and
um and you know help help get the brand
established and
um and it was actually great fun when it
when it was going well and it was
actually terrifying when it wasn't it
was the first um time that uh well five
people had actually tried to cross the
Atlantic five people that died so it was
it was the it was the attempt to try to
do it differently than the others had
done it and that was to fly in the jet
stream at 35 000 feet where you've got
very strong winds to be above the bad
weather
um and um uh and you know we were the
first and then and then foolishly we
decided to do the Pacific
um and a lot a lot of exciting things
went wrong on the way but we missed Los
Angeles I think by two and a half
thousand miles which is what we were
aiming for and ended up in the Arctic
but um but they were they were great
adventures and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is stop getting stuck with Ray
dalio the greatest problem of mankind I
believe wow that's a big statement the
greatest problem of mankind
and it is an exceptional problem at this
moment in time
is people having opinions that they're
stuck on
that
um they won't you know like I have to
have my opinion and that's right and so
on because it prevents them
from
um resolving it from moving forward to
finding the best answer from
compromising and or doing you know so
like everybody's arguing over everything
and and they and you know they're it's
almost like they're killing each other
and and we're in a society
um you know I have another principle
which is when the causes that you're
behind are more important to you and
others than the system the system is in
Jeopardy so do you are you just
literally going to go fight so here we
are as we think will we fight or we have
or will we have protocols for having
thoughtful disagreements and getting
past them
you guys are just getting started you're
not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I have the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends are for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day
kick start your day get going in your
day to give you a sense of respect for
yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that son up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today maybe today when I go into this
meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
beat the Sun up
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know how billionaires think and
get some success advice from the top
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there don't say it's
all going to be great you know I'll do
this and I'll do that and you know I'm
just marking time to get to be over that
I've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age I mean it just
isn't it